i'll tell you what
really concerns me about your
perspective
i think that there are a lot of genius
ideas inside of people who don't
have the stomach for conflict and
derision
and i think a lot of those people are
female
and i think that until we come up with a
world in which we can swat down the
trolls
where we can actually cause the trolls
not to ruin everything and i don't
necessarily mean by shutting them up i
don't necessarily mean by
being brutal to them but somehow
separating off people who are working
and people who are trolling
i think that we're losing a huge amount
of human genius in part
because women in particular
are not necessarily going to push an
idea
if it results in 10 years of being
derided
very few men are willing to do that
either
but there are some of us who are so dumb
that we will pigheadedly
stick to an idea for 10 years even if
the world collapses
i don't think that there are as many
women who are going to make that
calculation even if they know the idea
is correct and
one of the things that i believe
technology can help us fight the trolls
of all definitions of troll like i
believe that a better twitter can be
built
interesting i do not i don't believe
that a twitter successor can be built
that solves
most of the problems i think you can
always improve what we have
but i don't think that converges in
something that really works because i
think ultimately the problem isn't
twitter the problem is us
for example i've recently made a very
disturbing
realization which is
academics and trolls have very many
similar behaviors
absolutely it's largely a trolling
community
i tend to believe that the trolls
are not it's like the peter thiel many
mind
idea yeah which in all of the trolls
there's the possibility of goodness and
all you have to do
not all you have to do what you have to
do is create technology that
incentivizes
them to uh to embrace
to to discover to embrace to practice
the the better angels of their nature
and
i believe that like the people actually
want
to do that the trolls is a short-term
dopamine rush of uh
childish toxicity that all of us want to
overcome i believe that like
deep within we want to overcome that i i
i
try to keep myself from believing what
you believe
because you'll be disappointed if it's
not because it's dangerous because
a lot of these people are implacable
foes and there aren't many of them but
when you meet somebody who's like
yeah i just like screwing people up i'm
here for the pain
i i just believe even in them there's a
good there's a wonderful book that i'm
going to recommend to you
where i hope this comes from maybe i've
got the source wrong but
in any event it's a great book called
the maximum city
about bombay and i believe
the the conceit is that the author um
leaves bombay as a kid and comes back as
an adult he realizes
he has to rediscover the city because he
can't live in the city he left
so he gets in contact with all of the
weird areas of the city and one of them
is the underworld
he hangs out with the police but in the
underworld he's talking to contract
killers
and he says you know it's really weird
everybody pleads for their life
right before i kill them and they always
say this thing about i've got a
i've got two kids at home he says never
say that to a contract killer because we
have terrible relationships with our
parents
it doesn't endear us to you and that's
just
oh wow so there's a minus sign in front
of that statement you're sitting there
saying you know i've got a
three-year-old it's like
okay well i'm going to take this pos out
of
out of that kid's life maybe he'll have
a chance you don't know how people are
wired
and as much as i hate to say it there
are people whose wiring is so disturbing
and so different from yours that you
will never guess
why you can't reach them or how much
pleasure they may have gotten because
they may have gone over a point of no
return
nevertheless you are just a smart
guy who is using his intuition to make a
hypothesis
you do not know this for sure no and
i am you know whatever the hell i
am uh that has a different hypothesis
that even
in the darkest human beings that that
seem to be
only full of evil there's a good person
there that could be discovered
and that's one of the reasons i love
doing your show is that you have these
beliefs
even as a russian
[Laughter]
the russian special as you know the
russian
there is a weirdness which is a total
cynicism and total idealism
yeah locked together right that's very
much part of the russian character
you